This just in to CNN.
House Republicans say they have evidence that
members of the Biden family received millions
of dollars in payments from foreign entities
in China and Romania.
The Republican chairman of the house oversight
committee James comer releasing some of these
details moments ago.
CNN's Sara Murray is joining us.
What exactly was comer involved is Joe Biden.
>> Comer just did a press conference essentially
saying there are members of the Biden family
who received payments from entities linked
to Romania, linked to China and that some
of these payments took place while Joe Biden
was the vice president, and of course, James
comer is using this to try to further his
argument that he's trying to make that there
are members of the Biden family who
[9:53:20 AM]
members of the Biden family who enriched themselves
on the family name and that somehow the current
president was involved even though there is
no proof of that, but take a listen at what
comer said in his press conference just this
morning.
>> To be clear, this committee is investigating
president Biden and his family's shady business
deals that capitalize on Joe Biden's public
office and risked our country's national security.
The president, when confronted with this information,
said it wasn't true.
Instead of being honest with the American
people, president Biden has claimed since
the 2020 election that his family has not
received money from China.
That was a lie in 2020 and he continues to
lie to the American people now.
The Bidens have received millions of dollars
from China.
It is inconceivable that the president did
not know it.
>> This certainly raises
[9:54:22 AM]
>> This certainly raises questions about hunter
Biden's business activities and they don't
make allegations in the report that any of
the payments are illegal and they don't show
any payments directly linked to Joe Biden,
and the white house each before the comer
press conference was slamming it that he has
a way of playing fast and loose with the facts
and baseless innuendo.
>> The detail coming out.
What this means for hunter Biden something
very different for Joe Biden in terms of it,
right now